[Música]
ahora si entramos en nuestro segmento de
salud de directo américa está con
nosotros más romeros a la mar bienvenida
vamos a hablar de los problemas para
acceder a la salud de muchas personas en
palestina le pregunto entonces cuál es
esta situación que enfrentan los
palestinos si vamos a hacer primero un
repaso general de cómo es el acceso a la
salud en estos territorios palestinos
que recordemos que según la onu se
consideran territorios ocupados para
empezar hay una serie de problemas
derivada de por ejemplo los bloqueos
económicos que suceden en el enclave de
gaza particularmente que hace que por
ejemplo no se pueden portar material o
medicamentos con regularidad que más
ocurre también una falta pues esa
sistemática de infraestructura de muchos
hospitales que hacen que muchos
palestinos tengan que desplazarse por
ejemplo a hospitales de jerusalén este
para poder ser tratados como ahora
veremos más pero pues también recordemos
que el estado de israel' muchas veces es
quien da los permisos para estas
transiciones entre los distintos
territorios y sin estos permisos o si se
ralentiza obstaculiza de alguna forma
eso también impide que muchas personas
lleguen a tiempo por ejemplo pues a
recibir tratamientos que necesitan esto
se refleja de una forma bastante
dramática en las cifras vamos a repasar
las tasas de mortalidad de algunas de
las enfermedades que se encuentran entre
las 10 de las primeras y las principales
10 causas de muerte tanto en israel como
en palestina vemos que tanto en las
enfermedades que necesitan una atención
inmediata como un derrame cerebral como
por ejemplo en las enfermedades crónicas
como la diabetes la tasa de mortalidad
es mucho más alta en los territorios
palestinos que en israel precisamente
pues por esta falta de acceso a la salud
especialmente dramático resaltar en las
cifras de los transtornos neonatales que
también pues son casi el 55 veces más en
los territorios palestinos los problemas
que existen y las muertes que causan que
en israel entonces bueno este es un poco
el repaso de esta situación general que
vemos esta situación mar que le pregunto
cómo se produce entonces en el día a día
de los palestinos pues precisamente
vamos a ver esto en un hospital se llama
augusta victoria es uno de los seis
hospitales de las redes de
jerusalén-este y actualmente están
enfrentando una crisis financiera sin
precedentes la autoridad nacional
palestina les debe millonaria y por otro
lado la unión europea está bloqueando
algunos países de la unión europea está
bloqueando un fondo de ayuda del cual se
destinarían 13 millones a este hospital
porque hay algunos países que creen que
en los libros de texto palestinos se
induce a la violencia y al antisemitismo
entonces ahora esto ha provocado que la
unidad de oncología se encuentra al
borde de pues al colapsar y ya se ha
visto forzada a rechazar nuevos
pacientes sobre el terreno no se envían
en esta historia a nuestros compañeros
yanira gómez muñoz y federico cue
barberena
en la unidad de cáncer del hospital
augusta victoria el doctor giuseppe
saluda más personal cap a 100 test está
vacío
aquí deberían tratarse a diario unos 80
palestinos pero el vacío no se debe a
una remisión de la enfermedad sino a una
crisis de fondos desde septiembre de
2021 el centro se ha visto obligado a
rechazar a 500 nuevos pacientes ya
posponer la atención de más de 600
con
interrumpir protocolos para mí es una
catástrofe
alrededor del 40% de nuestros pacientes
no pueden venir al hospital a recibir
sus tratamientos a tiempo debido a la
falta de medicamentos
hasta ahora el hospital había sorteado
la deuda de más de 70 millones de
dólares de la autoridad palestina
también la pandemia y la inasistencia de
eeuu bajo donald trump pero no contaba
con que la unión europea bloqueará su
contribución anual por el rechazo de
algunos miembros al contenido de los
libros de texto palestinos
las consecuencias las sufren pacientes
como esta mujer de 39 años con cáncer de
mama y destinada al quirófano si no
llega el fármaco por el que espera hace
casi dos meses
confía en nosotros
por supuesto que confío pero necesito mi
tratamiento y por favor les pido que
intenten no hacer lo mismo con otras
mujeres
[Música]
este hospital luterano es la única
opción para los enfermos de cáncer de
gaza y el mejor para los de cisjordania
ocupada
soy de ebro la distancia del hospital de
ramala es grande además proveen otros
hospitales pero no encontré la atención
que hay aquí perderíamos mucho si este
centro desapareciera
a la búsqueda de dinero está volcado el
doctor fadi no solo para sostener los
tratamientos que peligran sino socorrer
a quienes quedaron al margen
esto es muy frustrante no sólo para mí
sino para todos mis doctores
a veces caemos en depresión estamos
intentando llevar nuestra voz a la
comisión europea para decirles que
bloquear este dinero está hiriendo a
nuestro hospital a nuestros pacientes se
trata de vidas humanas no de política
más allá de algunas ayudas de la onu y
alemania fadi deja claro que si no se
liberan los fondos europeos a fines de
junio la unidad de cáncer podría dejar
de funcionar
aprovechamos también para cerrar
recordar que este acceso a la salud debe
estar garantizado según el derecho
internacional humanitario' por israel en
los territorios que se consideran
ocupados por la onu mar gracias por toda
la información de salud nos vemos mañana
con más pasamos entonces a analizar el
tema para darle pie a nuestro segundo
meta del día